now adhere with reaction to all of these
developments out of Washington tonight
we're joined by Florida congressman also
gubernatorial candidate who I have said
I want to win to be the next governor
and Ron de Santos is with us sir okay
I know these are just released we're
pouring through the 49 pages we know the
hatred struck and page have for
President Trump what do you got so far
well Shawn I I think this is incomplete
production I mean we know their texting
habits of how often they were texting in
other periods and so this is the period
December of 2016 during the Trump
transition all the way up until the
firing of James Comey and then the
appointment of Robert Mueller is a
special counsel if there's only 40 some
pages there there's gaps some of the
stuff is incomplete so I don't think
that this is a full production I think
there's more questions that this raises
and we're gonna have to go back to the
Justice Department and asked them why
they weren't able to recover the full
struck page text message congressman I
had multiple sources telling me tonight
that they suspect that there were other
devices used as well did you get that is
that your interpretation looking at this
yes and and we've also have reason to
believe that they were using something
called the clean Gmail which is everyone
has access to the account and you just
do messages in the draft and then
respond to drafts so you're not actually
sending emails so yeah there's a lot of
things that they do are using iMessage
so we've got to get all of that that we
can get for sure but this is not it I
mean you Shawn you've documented these
are love birds they had all this hatred
for the president they were very quick
to put their opinions about everything
that was going on and yet here you know
you'll just see gap after gap so I'm not
satisfied okay I want to want to go to
the issue how was a possible Peter
strucker's in the middle of all this he
interviewed general Flynn apparently
didn't think he was lying how did he get
charged then but also interviewed
Hillary Clinton but that was in July of
2016
it was early May of 2016 where it was
struck and Comey himself right
narration that actually used the
standard the legal standard that means
Hilary would have broken the law
they changed the wording to take that
part out and the original drafting also
had in that multiple foreign
intelligence agencies had hacked into
Hillary Clinton's email server and that
means top secret classified special
access programming information was in
fact obtained by America's enemies and
none of it would have been redacted sir
so if you or somebody who was on
Hillary's campaign team at the time and
you could have suggest changes to be
made to that statement you would have
suggested exactly the changes that Peter
struck insisted on to try to reduce
Hillary's level of recklessness and her
culpability and so he was involved in
the thick of that case and here's I
think why it's so troubling with what
structs conduct what does he do after
Comey exonerates Hillary a couple weeks
later he opens up a collusion case
against the Trump campaign based off
what we now know was a two-page document
with no actual intelligence and then
eventually they supplemented it with a
fake dossier paid for by the Democrats
but struck was the prime driver not only
behind exonerating Hillary but then
pursuing this collusion fairy tale and
that ultimately led to the appointment
of Muller
unbelievable congressman we are not
going to let up this is there are
apparently 50,000 of them and apparently
1.2 million pages that the Inspector
General has that Congress needs to get
and and I'm just in Congress if they
don't hand them over soon you must hold
these people in contempt and worse Thank
You Westen all right congressman thank
you